welcome to this video playing jarrow
from belgium let's see that Trump
recently had experimented a bit with it
now some good good game so why not try
it again yeah Bishop d3 is how they play
it I play Knight f6 here the
recommendation of Boris of rooks it's
not exactly grade or anything this
retreat but it's it's interesting leads
to very solid play I know that this is
supposed to be dangerous for black but
my theory Maya theoretical knowledge
stops exactly after d5 so I think Bishop
g3 looks fairly normal okay night before
probably one positive thing I mean
Knight c3 looks yeah i mean this must be
right otherwise i don't know Bishop b5
does not make much sense and yeah this
looks this looks a tad and risky for
black okay if I just play a 3 you take
you for am I not just winning this pawn
or is f5 coming or I don't know i just
take this
okay so just just retreat I guess and
I'm threatening efore keeping keeping
this pawn forever and ever and I don't
see what he does against it the only
drawback of my position is the slightly
sorry about that the slightly off site
bishop on g 3 which is currently just
biting okay
um II for Queen B 2 nite GE to the shop
moves if I will be 2nite a 4 there is a
twin B 5 which at least keeps the
material for the moment I can also just
play Quincy one to be to be perfectly
honest just keep this pawn I mean I can
play efore efore queen bee 292 for for
an advantage but yeah I can just take
that just can just keep the pawn there
is some no reason not to ok trying to to
harass my bishop so II for is going to
play age form where I can take you five
then and now this is really really ok
yeah I can take me five
desperado Bishop with all the possible
complications in the center you
shouldn't forget that the night on a
success Vidya misplaced and takes a
while to to ever do something serious in
this position f takes you five I just
take f5 and I've two pawns up even and I
really don't see what else I mean it can
take efore night takes fe5 and I'm going
to play C form fortify the g5 permanent
he's got a dead bishop on a fade that's
that's that's interesting that's an
interesting try okay I have to sorry I
have to react to that g3 looks kind of
weird Knight takes bishop legs that's a
good move here that Lister is rather
irritating ok so what he wants to do is
after Bishop retreating wants to take a
form play rupee idea ok I'm going to
take the bishop now yeah so I'm going to
give this back of course how exactly
with 92 or is there something f4f if I
if there is no
or maybe Knight f3 actually why not
Knight f3 he takes with the part I have
94 or 95 95 this is even better i am 95
and then 94 this keeps them stuff nicely
controlled
yeah so you can take on f5 I don't mind
and possibly Queen have three years on
so protect this and I'm going to Castle
long here not short so that there's no
Queen to d2 made any anytime canceling
long here is just much better now I
still have my extra pawn yeah bishop age
6
so I cannot cancel long
but Bishop age six there is 96 yeah so i
can cancel long sometimes it takes
changes to see those things it is I mean
just just just winning here Bishop e3 93
with the p's up and if he takes with the
jeep on i have f form he can take f form
yeah you can take form for this check
but it shouldn't shouldn't really be a
big issue check so i can take f5 as well
maybe this is the easiest just check
just take here until I give give back
some material so that those pawns are
disappear
check the material advantage is still
Queen g3 was much AG of Bishop if I'm
okay I just wanted to push my queen is
hanging Wow my queen is saying haha that
was this was a bit lucky that it didn't
really that it didn't really matter that
much because his was hanging with the
promotion and everything I we yeah it
was slightly d7 was really a shaky move
but it is in fact probably the best move
but I really didn't see that my queen
was saying okay yeah this was an opening
disaster I don't really know what is I
don't really know what what what is
played here is this I don't know so
somewhere around here already felt a
little bit strange fruit like how are
you going to keep a five and a four and
and everything computer at least that
gives me a pretty big advantage already
hmm okay yet here this is this is almost
almost winning it's it's a pawn it's a
central pawn and really no compensation
whatsoever okay I went here each floor
Bishop change three yeah this was some
at least very irritating but g3 is a
good reply I guess it takes takes Knight
f3 is also good I was expecting bishop g
six actually but okay yeah I think this
is this is ok g4 is even stronger word
ok is this just keeps everything under
control check so it was looking at it
now here it was a pretty a pretty good
game
I own the check here of course I don't
need to take h3 I can take play rook e1
just a queen up but this is an easy way
to play the only thing that you should
do is you should recognize that your
queen hangs these happiness is good
anyway but attend raphy see that the
Queen was attacked okay well thanks for
watching